kaylynn city's gonna be late okay we'll
start it now I wanted to talk to you
guys about our toiletry campaigns well
you did meeting yeah someone didn't get
the memo yeah I don't even think we
could be friends anymore now Kayla
oh yeah Kailyn you're fired wholesome
co-worker ribbing so back to the
toiletry campaigns Kayla what are you
doing sitting down I just fired you you
weren't serious no of course not good
one Natalie
Kailyn sit down just cuz I'm the boss
now doesn't mean we can't joke around
like when I was the receptionist picking
these go out today it's too late you're
fired
more candy fired you only a wimp
accident that's it I don't even work
here
not anymore see you are joking right
I think so you think so honestly I just
was joking around a seat cool but now
I've fallen down the sort of rabbit hole
I'm not really sure how to get out of it
- just stop we get it it's cool you did
it but killing you actually are on thin
ice so maybe that's what makes the joke
so good it's sort of funny because it's
true type of thing it's not funny
because it's true though right because
it's not true
it's just a joke right what's funnier
neither well why does Caroline's opinion
matter cuz he doesn't work here anymore
do not keep feeding this Elliot sorry
you don't have to do this Natalie okay
just say just kidding and we'll all
pretend this didn't happen
thank you guys would still think I'm
funny though right yes yes absolutely
but not too funny like you would still
take me seriously yes sweet Christ yes
gotcha okay Gillian I was kidding sit
down we'll move on oh that was fun
back to the toiletry campaigns I'm gonna
need all of you to pick up the slack now
that Kaylin has been terminated
pack your bags Kaylin and if you have a
badge
I'd like it
you